[Music]
whoever says there are never elections
in dictatorships is wrong last Sunday
the 3rd of December Venezuelans although
still unable to freely choose their
government were called to vote in a
referendum on a supposed common cause
esaka
Guyana Venezuela has had a territorial
dispute with Guyana for more than 100
years the small neighboring country has
made discoveries of major oil deposits
in recent years the sovereignty of
159,50 42 km that's just under 100,000
square mil which represents
74.2% of the Guyanese territory is under
discussion and to establish its position
the Venezuelan government organized a
referendum the result of course was
predictable 90% supported the thesis now
defended by the chavista government that
is to try to recover Guyana esaka what
did you expect they are hardly going to
call a referendum to lose it
the fact is that in spite of being a
long-standing dispute in recent months
the chavista government has carried out
an escalation on this issue that has not
been seen for a long time the tension is
red hot and take note because we are not
talking about a Judicial appeal or
anything like that but about the real
banging of War drums Maduro dusts off
the claim on Venezuelan sovereignty over
Guyana esba Lula wants to avoid a war
between Venezuela and Guyana and sends a
trusted to mediate that's the way things
are the state apparatus has promoted the
vote with Billboards concerts
merchandising military rallies and
incessant advertising on social media
the result according to the government
just over 10 million Venezuelans around
50% of the electorate turned out to vote
of which more than 90% voted in favor of
the government's territorial claim to
the esao nevertheless the reality may be
very different the number of Voters is
hard to believe the polling stations
were practically empty it is most likely
that only a fraction of the 10 million
voters that the regim claims were there
actually participated in the process but
this is Venezuela and be there as it may
now the chavista regime has a new Wild
Card up its
sleeve the fact is that all this
surprising tension that has now suddenly
been Unleashed around Guyanese
Venezuelan relations leads us to ask
ourselves several questions what exactly
does the chavista regime intend to do
with this referendum why is there so
much interest in this issue all of a
sudden How likely is it that an armed
conflict could break out in the S A kebo
today we're going to answer all these
questions and we are going to do it with
Jake the new member of the visual
politic team fire up your engines and
let's get
[Applause]
[Music]
started to understand how and when this
conflict arose we have have to go back
to the colonial era specifically when
Guyana was under the control of the
British Empire and Venezuela was under
the control of the Spanish Empire the
Guyana esba was part of the captaincy
general of Venezuela a Spanish Dominion
created by Charles FD in 1777 yet the
first intrusion in the area was not
British but Dutch it was the Dutch who
in the absence of effective control by
Madrid established the first non-spanish
colonies in the
region however after a series of wars
and clashes the Great weakened Dutch
lost control of their settlements and
the British became the deao rulers in
1796 shortly thereafter the Anglo Dutch
Treaty of 1814 and the Congress of
Vienna in 1815 resulted in the colonies
of esoko demera and bis being officially
seeded into the United Kingdom thus was
born British Guyana which bordered with
the newly created Venezuela on the west
what's more in parallel to the British
possession of Guyana Caracas gained its
independence from Spain the problem was
that the boundaries between the two
territories were not at all clear
therefore in 1841 the Royal geographical
Society hired Robert Herman schamburg a
German naturalist to draw the borders of
British Guyana with Venezuela in the
west and with Dutch Guyana now Surinam
in the East this study ended up
establishing the so-called shamberg line
a border that effectively gave an
additional 80,000 Square km to British
Guyana before the establishment of this
line the esaka river had been the
natural border between the two
territories well it is precisely this
stretch the one between the esaka river
and the shamberg which today has
triggered political and even military
tension between Georgetown and Caracas
so the question is why has it never been
possible to reach a solution in 170
years has it really never been possible
to clarify the situation in the area on
what basis is chavismo now launching
such an aggressive claim well in order
to understand this we have to dig a
little deeper into the history books
Let's
Go from judicial traps to the war
scenario
after sealing its independence in 1821
and with the death of Simon Boulevard
around 1830 Venezuela entered a spiral
of internal violence as several local
cilos sought to take control over the
country it was just at that time that
the shamberg line was drawn so that when
things calmed down in Caracas the
British presence west of the esoko was
already facted around 1880 the then
Venezuelan president Antonio Guzman
Blanco began to denounce British
interference at the international level
to the point that in 1895 the issue was
based on the agenda of the White House
itself the dispute has reached such a
stage as to make it now incumbent upon
the United States to take measures to
determine with sufficient certainty for
its justification what is the true
divisional line between the Republic of
Venezuela and British Guyana the message
of American president forced London to
accept an international arbitration
award and in February 1897 Venezuela the
United States and Great Britain reached
an agreement to settle the development
of a judicial process that would settle
the territorial dispute once and for all
however the word agreement is not the
most fitting word to describe the
Venezuelan
position why do I say this well because
one of the rules agreed upon by
Washington and London included leaving
Venezuela out of the arbitration
tribunal while the defense of the sou
American country in the trial would be
in the hands of American lawyers thus
Caracas was a mere spectator in the
judicial process that took place in
Paris in 1899 a hearing in which one
party was not even present the tribunal
composed of two British two American and
one Russian as a neutral judge
determined that the shamberg line did
indeed form the real border between
Venezuela and Gana thus legitimizing
British rule west of the esaka river
Venezuela was granted perhaps as some
compensation sovereignity over the
mouths of the orinoko river a strategic
Enclave but of course much more limited
than the Venezuelan
claim so the question is how is this
Court ruling Justified well 100 years
later it's still not entirely clear the
reasons for the Court ruling were never
published and that is why since then
Venezuela considers the British
occupation as a usurpation later in the
1950s Venezuela experienced significant
economic growth under the dictatorship
of Marcos Perez Jimenez a guy who years
after being overthrown made it public
that for decades the South American
country has maintained plans to
militarily recover the territory of the
eso
but things did not stop there in 1962
Venezuela began to claim before the
United Nations that the arbitral award
of 1899 should be considered null and
void due to suspicions that the
resolution was intended to favor British
interests as a result in 196 6 Venezuela
and the United Kingdom agreed to seek a
new mechanism to replace the Paris
arbitral award the problem is that this
happened just a few weeks before London
granted Independence to Guyana from that
moment on the talks would have to be
between Caracus and Georgetown and not
surprisingly although the agreement
reached between London and Caracas
considered a maximum period of four
years for the party to reach an
agreement the new guyane government
wanted nothing to do with the matter in
the end the situation stalled with the
occasional military altercation in
between but the truth is that little by
little this issue faded away until now
when Nicholas Maduro has put it back on
the table as I think most of you know
Maduro is the current leader of the
so-called bolivarian Revolution but he
is neither its ideologist nor the one
who started it and that is why one
important question we have to ask
ourselves at this point is how has the
relationship of the bolivarian
Revolution really been with this
territorial dispute to what extent did
this issue concern the leader of this
revolution commandant Chavez well get
ready because I think there there are
going to be a lot of surprises
here Chavez and Guyana the honeymoon
that was
not the coming to power of Hugo Chavez
marked a real turning point in the
history of Venezuela in 1998 he launched
the bolivarian revolution which included
a complete overhaul of the Venezuelan
political system and do you know what in
spite of his well-known Anti-Imperialist
and anti-western discourse from the
outset of his government Hugo Chavez
tried to fraternize with his Guyanese
neighbor a feeling of Brotherhood
towards Guyana has been born which we
have come to strengthen and I must tell
you that I continue to study the maps of
Guyana but not to launch paratroopers or
put tanks of War but to see where the
route between Venezuela and Georgetown
is going to come or to see where we can
promote common development projects in
fact Petr caribbe an alliance created in
2005 to allow Caribbean countries to buy
Venezuelan oil under preferential
conditions was one of the key
instruments of the international policy
of 2st Century socialism well guess what
Guyana was one of the first countries to
join this initiative hydrocarbon Supply
agreement signed with Guyana the
agreement signed within the framework of
the Petr caribbe energy cooperation
agreement will allow the neighboring
country to receive gasoline diesel jet
A1 fuel oil and asphalt according to its
requirements the established Supply
represents 50% of the nation's daily
consumption as you can see Georgetown
thus became energetically dependent on
Caracas a position that gave the
Venezuelan government enormous influence
the 2009 Central Bank of Guyana report
recorded a debt of us $143 million with
Venezuela equivalent at that time to 15%
of the external public debt and it was
expected that by 2010 the debt would
amount to approximately us $180 million
but in spite of everything the eso issue
was never put up for
discussion in fact chavz treated Guyana
as if both countries were VI victims of
Anglo ameran
imperialism many were critical at the
time that Venezuela was losing a
historic opportunity to try and solve
its long-standing territorial claim
these criticisms increased when Guyana
began to search for oil Guyana oil
exploration reignites Venezuelan spat
the opposition accused the government on
Wednesday of ignoring guyana's oil
exploration in a border region claimed
by Venezuela and at this point the big
question is why on Earth do Hugo Chavez
do nothing to try and recover the es
aibo well the thing is that chismo had
other priorities above all his political
confrontation with
Colombia in fact in 2009 prior to the
installation of us bases in Colombian
territory ch dared to suggest that war
could be Unleashed in the
region that is why Chavez sought to
isolate the non-socialist countries of
the region little by little and to
achieve this he tried to become
something like the sugar daddy of the
Caribbean and that is exactly what
allowed Guyana to take advantage of the
Venezuelan oil bargain while Caracus
sheld its historical confrontation
ironically during this entire stage the
Venezuelan Ministry of of Foreign
Affairs was headed by Nicholas Maduro
himself who of course was completely
aligned to the leader strategy precisely
for this reason the subject of the eso
only became relevant again in 2013 after
Travis's death numerous oil companies
began to confirm the existence of oil
deposits in the continental shelf of the
Guyana
esba in spite of everything Maduro did
not go beyond simple protests that it
was of little importance until the
second half of 2023 when suddenly a kind
of nationalist fervor broke out in in
the bolivarian government so the
question is why just now what on Earth
does chismo gain by Reviving this
controversy well let's take a
[Music]
look playing with
fire Chism Mo's interest in resuming the
controversy with Guyana is full of
inconsistencies an example of this can
be found in the referendum questions
themselves a survey of the population
composed of five questions with complex
wording but two of them in particular
are the ones that cause concern do you
agree with Venezuela's historical
position of not recognizing the
jurisdiction of the international court
of justice to resolve the territorial
dispute over the Guyana esba do you
agree with the creation of the state of
Guyana esba and the development of an
accelerated plan for the integral
attention of the current and future
population of that territory including
among others the granting of Venezuelan
citizenship and identity cards in
accordance with the Geneva agreement and
international law consequently
incorporating said state in the map of
Venezuelan territory these two questions
give the Venezuelan State a high-risk
popular mandate in the first place
disregarding the international court of
justice practically leaves the conflict
without any possible diplomatic solution
and this is where the second problem
arises in the absence of diplomatic
Solutions what is left and that's not
[Music]
all Venezuela is considering the
territorial annexation of the esbo
something that not surprisingly could
only occur through the use of
force impul in Guyana the alarm Bells
have gone off after all what is at stake
is 74% of guyana's territory and the
vast majority of an oil production that
is continuing to grow Guyana says before
icj that refer in Venezuela for disputed
zone is an existential threat for the
guyan what is at stake is much more than
their territorial extension and you see
since guyane crude oil production began
to take off in 2015 the country is
experiencing almost exponential growth
to the point that in a few years it
could become the richest country in
South America but wait a minute visual
politic viewers let's not be fooled is
it really possible that all this
nationalist trickery is about the es
aibo in principle that's hard to believe
because the contradictions are plain to
see
as you can see according to Nicholas
Maduro himself guyana's supposed change
of attitude occurred in 2015 so why did
they wait eight years to protest so
vigorously if this territory is so
interesting for chismo why didn't they
try to recover it before when conditions
were more more suitable well pay
attention because the truth is that
there is something fishy going on
[Applause]
here what you have just seen is the
Argentine dictator leopardo fortunata
gter celebrating before thousands of
argentines the recovery of the malvinas
in the first week of April 1982 today we
know that the decision to occupy these
islands that were under British
sovereignity had a lot to do with the
loss of legitimacy of the Argentine
dictatorship let's just say that the
territorial cause was AR ruse to try to
recover political capital and social
support for remaining in power the
result an absolute disaster the British
sent a fighting force that expelled the
argentines and hastened the fall of the
Argentine dictatorship the question is
is chismo seeking to generate a similar
situation
in theory there are several differences
first Ghana is not a British territory
but an independent nation so the
conflict would not involve a military
power secondly in a potential military
conflict the disparity of forces is
enormous Venezuela has some 137,000
troops on land sea and air while
guyana's Armed Forces number only about
5,000 despite the acknowledged
operational limitations of the
Venezuelan armed forces the scale of the
competition is simply irreversible for
Georgetown although the circumstances
would not be the same the objective of
chismo could be the same as that of the
Argentine military Hunter to avoid a
democratic opening at the cost of a
military conflict that exalts a
nationalist cause remember that both the
Venezuelan opposition and the US are
negotiating with the Madura regime to
hold clean elections in 2024 which
naturally would mean the regime's exit
from Power therefore for many analysts
the situation with gyana only seeks to
justify a state of emergency or internal
commotion to freeze the election process
there are also those who believe that
this past referendum was a means to
grease the Shaista electoral machinery
and to test the alterations of the
electronic vote that chavismo would seek
to use to perpetrate itself in power and
in the worst case scenario the tension
with Guyana could give Caracas a new
wild card in the negotiations with
[Music]
Washington be that as it may if one
thing's clear it's that in this whole
story there is one actor that will be
key in how events will unfold we are
talking of course about the Venezuelan
armed forces the point is that a state
of semi war or even an attempted evasion
would further strengthen the influence
of the military in the current bolian
government for the moment the military
High command has shown its commitment to
the esoko issue the question is whether
when it comes down to it they would
really be willing to start an armed
conflict for the sole purpose of
sustaining a political project is
falling apart perhaps they think that a
military intervention would be
shortlived because of guyana's inability
to defend itself however if attempted
it's likely that the conflict could
escalate into a regional and even
International level Laura Richardson US
Army General and Commander us Southern
command will visit Guyana July 25th to
27th to meet with the Guyana Defense
Force the US Embassy and Caribbean
Community leaders to discuss the US
defense partnership with Guyana and
kakom partners guyane Vice president us
defense officials to visit Guyana amid
dispute with Venezuela defense
cooperation between Georgetown and
Washington has grown considerably this
year the fact that this country is
becoming a major oil power led by Exxon
Mobile may have a lot to do with it
therefore although Guyana could not
resist the Venezuelan Invasion on its
own the likelihood of an International
Coalition coming to its Aid cannot be
ruled out visual politic Community
chismo now seems ready to cross a very
worrying red line to provoke a military
Skirmish in a region where War has been
been conspicuous by its absence but what
can I say in the visual politic team we
think that this is nothing more than a
new smoke screen to try and improve its
negotiating strength and above all to
create a breeding ground that will
destroy any possibility of holding free
elections in 2024 be that as it may the
cards are on the table but at this point
it's your turn did you know about the
dispute between Venezuela and Guyana do
you think Caracus would dare to invade
its neighboring country leave us your
answer in the comments and let's start a
debate and now if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like And
subscribe to your politic all the best
and see you next
[Music]
time